[Musique]
oui
des questions revendeurs magma qu'est ce
que c'est bien via jugement précédent à
une part est bon parce que voilà on peut
couper la passe que attend je réfléchis
un truc
[Musique]
m
à chaque fois que j'ai une ou deux
minutes pour parler de magma personne ne
comprend rien ce qui en fait il faut pas
une ou deux minutes pour s'exprimer mais
six mois alors six heures c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'ai fait une
musique très structuré très dense parce
que je me suis aperçu que dans une
musique improvisée comme par exemple le
jazz on perdait une énergie folle pour
pas grand chose parce qu'en fait les
énergies se perd dans mille idées
différentes c'est comme le meilleur club
du monde par exemple on met sur une
scène en lui dit fait rire la salle
alors même si ses meilleurs clubs du
monde faire des petites conneries mais
en fait je ne sais pas s'il va se faire
bien comprendre mais qu'à notre clown ce
qu'il lui faudra ces six mois six mois
pour travailler un numéro pour être très
dense très compact et alors ce moment là
on verra tout simplement tout son génie
le fera sortir après avoir médité un
numéro pendant six mois c'est pareil
pour la musique c'est pareil pour leur
engagement
[Musique]
le kobaïen c'est pas l'espéranto s'est
pas engagé intellectuelle c'est un
langage organique c'est à dire que il
est venu du plus profond on essaie de
retrouver la véritable source si je
regarde un arbre je me dis qu'elle est
le mot pour arbres c'est un peu en fait
pour la musique c'est la même chose on
laisse venir en aide qu'on se laisse
pénétrer
[Musique]
j'aurais dû devenir un musicien de jazz
et puis jouer dans les clubs de jazz
avec les musiciens français qui
regardent leur montre toutes les cinq
minutes
c'est la fin de la pause je pourrais pas
ce qu'il y avait un malaise je pense à
des musiciens comme jon poll trend qui
donnaient leur vie chaque note justement
je compte n'est pas une telle différence
en france que j'ai compris qu'ils
apprennent à faire en france il fallait
créer ce que coltrane avait créé aux
états unis musique on état d'esprit je
viens mode musique motivé c'est ça fait
je voulais servir avec ma batterie une
musique motivée par un batteur ce n'est
qu'un batteur s'est tous tapper s'il ne
joue pas une musique motivé soit bon ou
mauvais
[Musique]
la musique n'a pas bougé depuis six ans
et toujours la même on évolue toujours
comme on l'avait dit six ans c'est
toujours mon plus beau plus complexe
techniquement ou harmoniquement on
essaie toujours de faire un apport d'un
discale musique n'a pas changé mais les
musiciens ont changé ont évolué le
musicien a évolué pas tous et je pense
que ceux qui ne sont pas restés sont
ceux qui pouvaient pas l'assumer
magma guy locaux tué calaisien comment
se fait-il qu'on te retrouves au sein
d'un groupe venant de paris comme magma
bon en fait on peut appeler ça le destin
met en face je pense que c'était calculé
pas par moi je sais pas par qui mais la
seule chose que je sais c'est que c'est
pour moi le le commencement du véritable
travail à tous les niveaux et cela ne va
pas sans problème
ton rôle tu a succédé à une section de
cuivres est-ce que c'était très
difficile que ça a porté un très grand
changement de la musique de magma moelle
est le même que chacun que chaque
musicien et h f dans magma il n'y a pas
un violon n'y a pas une guitare il ya
400 coeur il ya tout un univers qui doit
parler
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu es jeune tu as 18 ans tuée violoniste
quel est ton chemin tu as fait le
conservatoire j'ai fait le conservatoire
oui enfin tout ça c'est pas c'est pas
tellement important
je les dis c'est pas le véritable
travail tout ça un véritable travail
tu peux me le dire ouais c'est ça la
recherche de l'équilibré intérieur de
façon et des potentiels à l'intérieur
c'était comme l'énergie c'est une chose
que j'ignorais comment ce pouvoir servir
de l'énergie je crois que c'est une
chose la chose la plus importante qui
régit l'homme en fait car on peut
rencontrer des jeunes qui sont déjà des
grands pères ça c'est une par le
christian melly tout à fait évitable
c'est à dire que en temps moi je pars du
principe qu'en tant qu'être humain on
n'a rien à dire
c'est à dire que on l'est on doit
laisser pénétrer en nous les
intelligence supérieure les sépare l'île
forme supérieure c'est-à-dire que on
doit on est un récit plan un récipient
plein qu'il faut vider pour laisser
entrer les choses merveilleuses de
l'univers bon c'est difficile à
expliquer ça mais
[Applaudissements]
il
on a tellement l'esprit embrumé par ben
tout le détail en fait qu'on ne voit
plus la raison majeure pour laquelle on
est ici et moi j'ai j'ai résolu le
détail le quotidien terminer au fond
ranger dans un petit casier et je laisse
mon cerveau ouvert à tous
[Musique]
rés
taxis
[Musique]
quand même
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
enfin bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah bon
[Musique]
à
ça
[Musique]
ap
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour tous